according to the Quran Jesus was a
prophet of Islam his followers were
Muslims and the gospel is the inspired
preserved authoritative word of Allah
but when we go to our earliest records
we find Jesus claiming to be the Divine
Son of God who would die on the cross
for sins and rise from the dead Jesus
followers proclaimed him as their Risen
Lord the gospel that Christians have
been reading for nearly 2,000 years
tells us that anyone who claims to be a
prophet rejects Jesus death resurrection
and deity as a false prophet and an
antichrist so if the Quran is right
about Jesus why does all of the
available evidence tell us that the
Quran is wrong about Jesus well our
Muslim friends have an answer the reason
our earliest evidence so thoroughly
contradicts Islam they insist is that
our earliest evidence was
corrupted but who corrupted it notice
that their options here are quite
limited Muslims can't blame Jesus for
corrupting the evidence since Jesus was
a Muslim Prophet according to the Quran
nor can they blame Jesus original
disciples for corrupting the evidence
since Jesus original disciples were
devout Muslims according to the Quran so
they need a villain who wasn't Jesus or
one of his original disciples but who
was still powerful enough to corrupt
Christianity in the first
century who had had that kind of power
in the first
century The Only Name that Muslims have
been able to come up with here is Paul
so if you've ever wondered why Muslims
spend so much time attacking Paul it's
not because Paul is somehow especially
untrustworthy or controversial it's
because they have no one else to blame
for Muhammad's abundant historical
blunders but there's a problem here it
only makes sense to blame Paul for all
of the evidence that contradicts
Muhammad's claims if Muhammad is
significantly more reliable than Paul if
Muhammad is less reliable than Paul it
makes no sense to point a finger at Paul
whenever Muhammad gets something wrong
in other words if I catch person a
making numerous false statements and I
ask him how I can trust him when he's
making so many false statements and he
says it's person B's fault he corrupted
all of the evidence and made my
statements seem false but person B turns
out to be far more trustworthy than
person a it becomes impossible to take
person a
seriously so the question we should be
asking is this whose claims about Jesus
are more reliable Paul's or
Muhammad's in this video I'm going to
offer a few reasons to trust what Paul
says about Jesus over what Muhammad says
about Jesus and when I say a few reasons
I mean 25 of them some of these reasons
taken individually wouldn't be enough to
reject what Muhammad says but when we
consider all of the reasons together
it's pretty clear that Muhammad's claims
about Jesus are about as reliable as a
CNN Special on the origins of Islamic
terrorism our records of Paul's life are
much earlier than our records of
Muhammad's life and here I don't just
mean that Paul came centuries before
Muhammad and so we have earlier sources
for Paul's life I mean that when we talk
about the teachings and deeds of Paul
the biographical sources we use are much
closer to the events they report than
the biographical sources we use when we
talk about the teachings and deeds of
Muhammad our earliest biographical
sources on Paul were written during the
lifetime of Paul
the book of Acts was written in the
early 60s before Paul was martyred and
it was written by a traveling companion
of Paul who was an eyewitness to many of
the details he reports we also have
numerous letters written by Paul himself
our earliest detailed biographical
Source on Muhammad isak's Sur Ras Allah
which was written more than a century
after Muhammad's death and we don't even
have what iban asak actually
wrote we have an Abridged version that
was sanitized by a later scholar and we
shouldn't forget that many Muslims don't
trust Ian isak when Muslims quote
stories about Muhammad they're usually
getting their information from sources
like sahkari and sah Muslim which were
written two centuries after the time of
Muhammad but it gets worse the main
reason for composing works like sahil
bukari and sah Muslim was that Muslims
were composing so many false stories
about Muhammad people didn't know what
to believe Scholars like bukari decided
that they needed to collect stories they
thought were accurate in order to
distinguish them from the ever
increasing supply of false
narrations now if Muslims during the
time of bukhari were inventing stories
about
Muhammad what about the generation
before that and the generation before
that and the generation before that two
centuries is a lot of time to make
things up that's why it's always good to
have sources written within the lifetime
of the person you want to know about or
at least within the lifetimes of the
eyewitnesses when we learn about Paul we
learn about him through first generation
eyewitness accounts when we learn about
Muhammad we learn about him through late
sources written by people who didn't
know him whose parents didn't know him
and whose grandparents didn't know him
people who were fishing for historical
facts in a sea of fabrication and
deception a few years ago the crumbling
historical foundations for the life of
Muhammad led the Islamic scholar
Muhammad Sven Kish to conclude that
Muhammad probably never
existed I don't agree with Dr kish's
conclusion about Muhammad's existence
but when even Muslim Scholars are
starting to recognize how difficult it's
become to take Muslim sources seriously
our confidence in the historical
Muhammad vanishes faster than a Muhammad
cartoon posted on Facebook in
Pakistan the Apostle Paul was a
brilliant scholar who defended his views
in Athens the intellectual capital of
the ancient world and in other major
cities he had discussions with the stoic
and epicurian philosophers of his day
and he could quote their sources to them
even antthony flu one of the 20th
Century's most impressive critics of
Christianity said that the Apostle Paul
possessed a first class philosophical
mind Muhammad by contrast was an
illiterate 7th Century Caravan Trader
now being an illiterate 7th Century
Caravan Trader doesn't make you wrong
just as being a brilliant scholar
doesn't make you right but when we're
dealing with claims about history and
Theology and various other topics having
some sort of Education helps not having
an education leaves you open to
obviously false Revelations because you
don't know enough to recognize them as
false this is why we find Muhammad
telling his followers that dual carain
traveled so far west he found the place
where the sun sets and that stars are
missile that Allah uses to shoot demons
and that semen is formed between the
backbone and the ribs these are exactly
the sort of absurdities we would expect
from someone who has no clue what he's
talking about and who therefore has no
clue whether his Revelations line up
with reality so in terms of intellectual
prowess Paul is to Muhammad what a
tenard theology professor at Oxford is
to an Internet troll whose most careful
investigations begin and end with a
Google
[Music]
search the Apostle Paul was a Pharisee
who studied under galel one of the
greatest Jewish rabbis of the first
century Paul knew the Old Testament
inside and out which is why he quotes
the Old Testament so frequently in his
writings this is important because Jesus
claimed to fulfill a variety of Old
Testament prophecies and you can't
really examine this claim if you don't
know what the Old Testament says
Muhammad was almost completely ignorant
of the Old Testament because his
knowledge of the Jewish scriptures was
limited to what he heard in
conversations not surprisingly despite
Muhammad's numerous interactions with
Jews in Arabia the Quran contains very
few quotations from the Old Testament
due to his ignorance of the scriptures
Muhammad couldn't tell the difference
between stories that were in the Torah
and therefore divine revelation and
stories from later Jewish writings and
commentaries some of which were so late
and so obviously fabricated they weren't
far beyond the level of bedtime stories
imagine how amusing it must be for
someone who specializes in Jewish
literac to read the Quran and find so
many fables being presented to Muslims
as Revelation Cain being taught how to
bury the dead by a raven Solomon
listening to a speech by an ant as a
general rule if you're going to
plagiarize history you don't start with
Mother Goose or the brothers
Grim but Muhammad just didn't know
enough to distinguish scripture from
non-s scripture Muhammad's ignorance of
the Old Testament is also noteworthy
because like Jesus he claimed to fulfill
Old Testament prophecies if Muhammad had
been more knowledgeable of the Torah he
would have known that he couldn't
possibly be a prophet for numerous
reasons for instance Muslim sources
report that Muhammad once delivered what
are now called The Satanic Verses to his
followers these verses promoted prayers
to three Pagan goddesses alot aloa and
manat Muhammad bowed down in honor of
these polytheistic verses and his
followers bowed down with him but a
little later Gabriel confronted Muhammad
about his sin Muhammad confessed in the
history of atab volume 6 page
111 I have fabricated things against God
and have imputed to him Words which he
has not
spoken so Muhammad admitted that he
delivered a revelation that didn't
really come from
God why is this important well in
Deuteronomy 18: 20 God declares but a
prophet who presumes to speak in my name
anything I have not commanded or a
prophet who speaks in the name of other
gods is to be put to
death Muslims claim that they respect
Moses but if Muhammad had delivered the
Satanic Verses during the time of Moses
Moses would have ordered the people to
to pick up stones and stone him to death
as the most obvious false prophet in
history Muhammad didn't realize this due
to his lack of familiarity with the
Jewish scriptures which is why the motto
of Islam has always been and always will
be ignorance is
bliss the apostle Paul was a
contemporary of Jesus and he spent much
of his time in first century Israel this
put Paul in a perfect position to gain
accurate historical information about
Jesus if you want reliable information
about a person it's pretty helpful being
a member of the person's own generation
and Paul was right there Muhammad was
born more than half a millennium after
Jesus death in a completely different
country since he couldn't read apart
from divine revelation his knowledge of
Jesus was limited to whatever stories
were popular in 7th Century Arabia this
is why when we read the Quran we find so
many stories about Jesus that are known
to be forgeries Mary giving birth under
a palm tree Jesus preaching when he was
still a baby Jesus giving life to clay
birds we know where these stories come
from and they don't come from the first
century now don't get me wrong the Quran
is an excellent excellent history book
if you're looking for a history of 2nd
through 7th Century Middle Eastern
forgeries but if you're looking for
historical information about Jesus the
Quran is a few conspiracy theories shy
of the D Vinci
Cod the Apostle Paul was fluent in
Hebrew Aramaic and Greek all of the
languages necessary for understanding
the Old Testament the claims of Jesus
and the earliest Christian writings
Muhammad couldn't speak any of the
relevant languages so any attempt to
understand the Old Testament the claims
of Jesus or the earliest Christian
writings would have required the help of
interpreters I normally wouldn't bring
this up as a problem but since Muslims
are obsessed with reading the Quran in
the original Arabic we can only assume
that the writings of Moses the teachings
of Jesus and the writings of Jesus
followers can only be understood in the
original languages Paul could do that
Muhammad couldn't Muhammad's ignorance
of the original languages leads to
further problems for example the Quran
refers to the book revealed through
Jesus as the injil but the Arabic word
inil is ultimately derived from the
Greek word yuelian meaning good news
so according to the Quran the book
revealed through Jesus was written in
Greek this makes absolutely no sense if
Jesus was only sent to his fellow Jews
as Islam claims but it makes perfect
sense if Jesus message was for the rest
of the world as well since Greek was the
international language of the time
interestingly the New Testament gospels
were written in Greek exactly what we
would expect given the quran's use of
the term inil but quite unexpected given
Muhammad's notion of Jesus life and
Mission not to mention Muhammad's
conviction that Revelations can't be
translated welcome to Islam the religion
that shoots its own foot off with its
ridiculous view of
language in 1 Corinthians 9:1 Paul
writes am I not free am I not an apostle
have I not seen Jesus our lord Paul met
the Risen Jesus on the road to Damascus
where Paul was on his way to hunt down
Christians and bring them to Jerusalem
to face
punishment as he was riding he saw a
light that was brighter than the sun all
around him he fell to the ground and
Heard a Voice say Saul Saul why do you
persecute me it is hard for you to kick
against the goats Paul cried out who are
you Lord and the voice
replied I am Jesus whom you are
persecuting now get up and stand on your
feet I have appeared to you to appoint
you as a servant and as a witness of
what you have seen and will see of me I
will rescue you from your own people and
from the Gentiles I am sending you to
them to open their eyes and turn them
from Darkness to light and from the
power of Satan to God so that they may
receive forgiveness of sins and a place
among those who are Sanctified by faith
in me an apostle is one who is sent Paul
was sent by Jesus himself hence we call
him the Apostle Paul but Jesus warned
his followers to beware of people like
Muhammad in Matthew 7 Jesus said Beware
of false prophets who come to you in
sheep's clothing but inwardly are
ravenous wolves you will know them by
their
fruits no one in history fits this
description of a false prophet more
perfectly than Muhammad Muhammad came to
Jews and Christians and claimed to be
their friends sheep's clothing but when
he became powerful enough he called for
their violent
subjugation ravenous wolf Jesus said
that we can recognize false prophets by
their fruits whether we look at
Muhammad's life or the impact he's had
on the world Muhammad's fruits are not
good a 2014 study by the world economic
Forum concluded that 18 of the 20 worst
countries in the world in terms of the
gender gap between men and women were
Muslim majority countries there have
been more than 30,000 deadly Islamic
terrorist attacks just since
911 concerning human rights abuses one
of the most pro-islamic news sites on
the planet The Huffington Post writes of
the countries with a high risk of
violations Syria Egypt Libya Mali and
guinea basau feel free to look up the
religious demographics of those
countries have seen the worst
deterioration of their human rights
situation geographically speaking
nations in the Middle East and North
Africa account for the vast majority of
the countries in the extreme risk
category
nations in the Middle East and North
Africa now what could they possibly have
in
common belief in Muhammad is what they
have in common so if we know false
prophets by their fruits as Jesus
claimed we know that Muhammad was a
false prophet the same way we know that
this is an orange tree except that we
have far far more evidence for our
conclusion about
Muhammad even though Paul received
Revelations telling him what to believe
about Jesus he was able to test these
Revelations by going to the
eyewitnesses some Muslims actually look
down on this if Paul really believed his
Revelations why would he test them but
Paul was smart enough to realize that
lots of people think they're getting
Revelations from God when they aren't so
if you think God is speaking to you one
day and you have an opportunity to
verify the message by taking a trip and
asking a few questions why not do it
intriguingly Allah invited Muhammad to
test his Revelations by going to the
people of the book Jews and Christians
in order to make sure that his
Revelations lined up with our
Revelations Muhammad occasionally
doubted the divine origin of the Quran
and in Surah 10 verse 94 of the Quran
Allah responded to Muhammad's doubts by
saying but if you are in doubt as to
what we have revealed to you ask those
who read the book before you so Muhammad
could go to the people of the book Jews
and Christians to confirm his
Revelations but if Muhammad had actually
done that Jews and Christians would have
told him that his revelation ations
contradict what's in the Torah and the
gospel on a fundamental level this is
when Muslims jump in and say but the
Torah and the gospel have been
corrupted really so Allah was inviting
Muhammad to confirm his Revelations by
going to people who've been reading
corrupt
books Islam would only line up with
corrupt books if Islam itself were a
corruption thank you my Muslim friends
for insisting again that your religion
is a Corruption of God's true
message I couldn't agree with you
more we know from first century sources
not only that Paul went to Jesus
original Apostles to test his
Revelations but also that the apostles
confirmed Paul's message and his
authority James Peter and John
recognized that Paul had been sent by
God to preach the gospel among the
Gentiles and they gave Paul what he
called the right hand of Fellowship in 2
Peter 3:15-16 the Apostle Peter one of
Jesus closest companions refers to Paul
as our beloved brother and he puts
Paul's letters in the same category as
Old Testament scripture now the apostles
couldn't explicitly confirm Muhammad's
message because Muhammad wasn't wasn't
born for another five centuries but
since the gospel preached by the
Apostles of Jesus was a message about
his sacrificial death his resurrection
from the dead and his divine nature all
of which contradict the Quran it's safe
to say that they would have regarded
Muhammad as an obvious heretic and a
false prophet according to the Apostle
John any preacher or teacher or Prophet
who denies that Jesus is the son of God
is an
Antichrist Muhammad denied that Jesus is
the son of
God I hope I don't need to complete the
syllogism for
you in Surah 18 Allah tells us that duul
carnine usually identified as Alexander
the Great traveled so far west he found
the place where the sun sets not only
can I guarantee that Alexander the Great
never found the place where the sun sets
we know that this was a popular story
during Muhammad's lifetime the story was
even circulating in a syc work titled
the Glorious Deeds of Alexander towards
the end of Muhammad's life earlier in
Surah 18 we read about the companions of
the cave a group of people who
supposedly went to sleep in a cave and
woke up 300 years years later this myth
goes back to Bishop Steven of Ephesus
around the middle of the fth century it
seems that Muhammad simply took the
stories that were popular during his
lifetime gave them an Islamic twist and
included them in the Quran what's
interesting is that even the pagans of
Mecca were better at recognizing fiction
than Muhammad was in Surah 6 verse 25
Allah says to Muhammad when they come to
you to argue with you the unbelievers
say these are nothing but fables of the
men of
old here we have pagans saying Muhammad
you don't really believe these stories
do you so we know that Muhammad was
extremely sloppy and gullible when it
came to stories about historical figures
which means that there's no way we can
accept him as a reliable source of
information about Jesus
Paul by contrast was far more careful in
transmitting stories as a Pharisee Paul
was obsessed with preserving and passing
on authoritative tradition Paul
describes his life as a Pharisee by
saying I was advancing in Judaism Beyond
many of my contemporaries among my
countrymen being more extremely zealous
for my ancestral
Traditions Paul's obsession with
tradition doesn't go away when he
becomes a Christian he just Chang
changes the source of authority as a
Pharisee he would have passed on
Traditions he obtained from respected
rabbis as a Christian he passed on
Traditions he obtained from Jesus
Apostles when we read what Paul says
about Jesus we're reading the words of a
man who was trained all of his life to
carefully and zealously preserve and
pass on authoritative tradition from
respected sources he's the polar
opposite of Muhammad one of whose
contemporaries said of him in Ian asak
page
243 Muhammad is all ears if anyone tells
him anything he believes
it a guy who has a reputation for
believing anything anyone tells him is
not the sort of guy you want telling you
what to believe about the most important
man in history
when Muhammad preached in Arabia there
weren't a lot of historians around and
the early Muslim Community didn't know
much about first century Christianity so
in this atmosphere of ignorance Muhammad
could say whatever he wanted to say
about Jesus and his followers wouldn't
know that he was wrong Muhammad could
say for instance as he does in Surah 4:
157 of the Quran that Jesus wasn't
killed and and wasn't crucified Muhammad
could say that Jesus claimed to be
nothing but a prophet and that Jesus
disciples were Muslims 7th Century Arab
Muslims wouldn't know any better and
even if they had it wasn't exactly safe
to question Muhammad's
teachings but we're not in that position
we have tons of ancient sources we have
a NeverEnding supply of historical Jesus
Scholars and we have the freedom to go
where the evidence points and when we
apply the Historical Method and the
tools of textual criticism to the
ancient records we find that the Muslim
view of Jesus as a man who claimed to be
nothing but a prophet who was never
killed who never rose from the dead and
whose followers were
Muslims this view reflects the
historical Jesus about as much as a
Huffington Post article claiming that
Muhammad was a worldclass feminist
reflects the historical
Muhammad but Paul's claims about Jesus
line up perfectly with everything we can
learn about Jesus historically and
because Paul was a contemporary of Jesus
and knew Jesus original Apostles if Paul
had preached a non-historical Jesus he
would have been condemned by the early
church and exposed as a false teacher
the reason he wasn't condemned and
exposed was that the Jesus preached by
Paul was the same Jesus who walked along
the shores of the Sea of Galilee who
performed Miracles who made claims that
no mere Prophet should ever make who
died on the cross for sins and who rose
from the
dead the Islamic Jesus is a kind of
Frankenstein monster pieced together
from 7th Century Arabian fables filtered
through Muhammad's 7th Century Arabian
theology a theology that was only one
step removed from its pagan Roots if
you've ever wondered why there are
Christian historical Jesus Scholars
Jewish historical Jesus Scholars a IST
historical Jesus Scholars and agnostic
historical Jesus Scholars but no muslim
historical Jesus Scholars it's because
Muslims are bound by the methods and
ideas of Muhammad the world's greatest
Authority on how not to do
history during the time of the judges
and the kings of ancient Israel the Jews
often turned to pagan gods and Pagan
forms of worship but by the first
century ad the time of Jesus and Paul
the Jews were done flirting with false
gods they had utter contempt for the
beliefs and practices of the pagans the
Apostle Paul had a strict Jewish
upbringing and would have therefore
shared the general Jewish view of
polytheism but Paul was no ordinary Jew
he was a Pharisee a member of the most
rigid sect and even among Pharisees Paul
was considered especially zealous why is
this relevant well there are Muslims who
try to explain the origin of
Christianity by claiming that Paul was
influenced by GRE Roman polytheists Paul
was so mesmerized by all of the Gods of
the pagans that he deified Jesus as a
form of compromise and that might make
sense to certain people assuming they
know absolutely nothing about the
Apostle Paul especially the fact that he
would have rather died a 100,000
horrible bloody deaths than compromise
his worship of the one true God Paul
became a Christian because he met Jesus
and his Encounter With Jesus caused him
to reexamine Old Testament prophecies
about the Messiah ultimately convincing
him that the law and the prophets were
all looking forward to the life death
and resurrection of Jesus there's no
room in Paul's reasoning for even a hint
of pagan
influence but there was no shortage of
pagan influence on Muhammad for instance
one of the five pillars of Islam is the
Hajj the annual pilgrimage to Mecca
which is saturated with paganism and
idolatry before Muhammad conquered Mecca
the pagans would take a pilgrimage to
Mecca where they would visit the cabba
and walk around it seven times they
walked seven circles around the cabba to
honor the seven planetary de ities which
they believed circled the Earth they
would kiss the black stone one of the
many stones in the ancient near East
that received worship they would run
back and forth between the hills of Safa
and Mara remind me what do Muslims do
when they take the pilgrimage to
Mecca they visit the cabba and walk
around it seven times just like the
pagans did they kiss the black stone
just like the pag pans did they run back
and forth between the hills of Safa and
Mara just like the pagans did but let me
guess if it looks like paganism and
walks like paganism and talks like
paganism it must be pure monotheism in
disguise
right Muslims believe that Muhammad's
Revelations were sent down from heaven
but we find all of the building blocks
of Islam in teachings and practices that
were common in Arabia during the 7th
Century there was Jewish monotheism in
Arabia along with countless Jewish
stories about various prophets some of
these stories ended up in the Quran
there were heretical Christian groups in
Arabia along with various stories about
Jesus Mary and others some of these
stories ended up in the Quran the
sabians who are mentioned in the Quran
prayed at all five of the times Muslims
prayed during their daily prayers and
they recited a
Creed there is no God but Allah many of
the polytheists of Arabia performed
ablutions these are ceremonial Washings
they took an annual pilgrimage to Mecca
they circled the cabba they kissed a
black stone that supposedly fell from
heaven what we know as Islam is a
collection of beliefs and practices that
were already circulating in Arabia when
Muhammad was born in
Mecca but not all of the beliefs and
practices that were circulating in
Arabia became part of Islam so why did
Muhammad accept some beliefs and
practices but reject
others what was the selection process to
answer this question we turn
to psychology Muhammad's father died
before he was born shortly after his
birth the future prophet of Islam was
sent to live with a foster family when
he was around four years old he was
taken away from the Foster family and
returned to his mother his mother died
when he was six and custody then fell to
his grandfather who died when he was
eight psychological studies show that
young children who experience so many
broken relations relationships tend to
exhibit certain patterns of behavior
later in life they often rebel against
Authority and tradition and they
frequently have a problem with Father
figures especially with viewing God as a
heavenly
father so how did Muhammad's
psychological framework Express itself
given the materials available in 7th
Century
Arabia not surprisingly he rebelled
against Authority and tradition
Muhammad attacked his own people
theologically socially morally and
economically and he violently subjugated
his own tribe and his own city as part
of his Rebellion against polytheistic
meccan culture Muhammad initially
aligned himself with Jews and Christians
but since Jews and Christians view God
as our heavenly father and Christians
believe that there's an eternal
fatherson relationship within the very
nature of God Muhammad's psychological
hostility towards father figures
compelled him to part ways with the
judeo-christian concept of God his
Revelations mocked Jews and Christians
for calling god father and eventually
demanded our violent subjugation due to
our theological views all of this is
exactly what we would expect given
Muhammad's traumatic childhood
experiences so Muhammad's claims about
Jesus don't seem to be a matter of
divine revelation or even a matter of
historical investigation they're a
matter of psychological manifestation in
other words Muhammad's childhood
experiences left him with some
psychological
predispositions and these
predispositions made certain beliefs and
practices seem more appealing than
others when the beliefs and practices of
7th Century Arabia are filtered through
Muhammad's psychological framework we
get Islam
why is this relevant well it's difficult
to trust what Muhammad says about Jesus
when his view of Jesus is the product of
his childhood trauma scaming through the
materials available in 7th Century
Arabia to find the beliefs and practices
that were most soothing to his damaged
psyche by contrast Paul's claims about
Jesus aren't simply a matter of wishful
thinking on Paul's part in fact they're
just the opposite Paul at first despised
Jesus and his followers and the message
they were preaching Paul was convinced
that God would only bless Israel if the
religious leaders eradicated heresy and
so he set out to destroy what he
regarded as the Christian heresy as he
was on one of his journeys to round up
Christians Paul suddenly began preaching
the faith that he was trying to destroy
and he claimed that he had changed
course because Jesus had appeared to him
Paul's conversion is significant because
he was initially extremely skeptical of
the claims of Christianity to the point
of wanting to see it utterly wiped out
he was so utterly confident that Jesus
was a false Messiah he was willing to
kill people who followed Jesus so we
can't accuse Paul of believing in
Christianity because he was biased in
favor of it and this adds another
dimension to the evidence for Jesus
resurrection Jesus Jesus appeared to a
lot of people after his death by
crucifixion more than 500 people were
Witnesses of the Risen Jesus but many of
them were followers of Jesus during his
Earthly Ministry so someone could argue
that they can't be fully trusted because
they were already loyal to Jesus maybe
they just saw what they wanted to see
they were grieving after Jesus death and
suddenly he appeared to them perhaps
they were only experiencing grief
hallucinations it would be
extraordinarily odd for so many people
to experience the same hallucination but
it's still an objection that critics
raise Paul however wasn't grieving over
Jesus so he wasn't in the frame of mind
to experience grief hallucinations and
yet he saw the same thing the other
Witnesses saw so Muhammad's message
flowed directly from his eclectic
religious surroundings and his AB normal
psychological state which raises further
suspicions about his
reliability Paul's message required a
radical transformation Something That
Shook him out of his previous View of
Jesus and brought him into line with
what Jesus followers were already saying
this transformation cries out for
explanation and I've never seen a better
explanation than that Paul really met
the Risen Jesus
our Muslim friends assure us that
Muhammad was the greatest man who ever
lived I have no clue what sources
they're reading when they say this and I
strongly suspect that they aren't
reading any sources they simply hear
wonderful things about Muhammad from
their leaders and they assume that these
wonderful things are true without ever B
in to investigate according to Muslim
sources Muhammad had sex with a
9-year-old girl he would brag to his
followers about having sex with nine
women and girls in a single day he
allowed his followers to rape their
female captives and to beat their
rebellious wives into submission he told
his followers that women are stupid and
immoral and that their testimony is
unreliable he tortured a man for money
he supported his religion through
robbery he had people assassinated for
making fun of him he ordered his
followers to execute anyone who leaves
Islam he bought owned sold and traded
black African slaves he referred to
Ethiopians as raisen heads and said that
Satan looks like a black
man not the sort of person you'd want as
your next door
neighbor what about Paul well before
Paul became a Christian he was violent
he persecuted Christians and had them
put in prison and sentenced to death but
apart from his early affinity for
forcing people to obey his
interpretation of the Torah Paul just
wouldn't do anything wrong in
Philippians 3:6 he says that according
to the righteousness under the law he
was
blameless this doesn't mean that he was
sinless but it does mean that no one
could point a finger at him and accuse
him of violating God's command
hands if you really wanted to criticize
Paul for something after he became a
Christian you could reasonably say that
he was extremely sarcastic at times and
that when people challenged his status
as an apostle he would boast about his
accomplishments and about working harder
than any of the other Apostles people
who have a problem with sarcasm and
boasting I happen to love them usually
don't like Paul's
personality but let's face it Paul isn't
the sort of person you'd need to hide
your 9-year-old daughter
from now to be fair Muhammad did share
certain positive characteristics with
Paul they both emphasized helping the
poor for instance but telling your
followers to help the poor doesn't
magically erase the centuries of spousal
abuse and child marriage and rape and
robbery and torture that Muhammad
justified through his revelation
and
example Adolf Hitler was an excellent
painter that doesn't mean he gets a free
pass on the millions of lives he
destroyed likewise Muhammad abolished
female
infanticide but that admittedly positive
accomplishment can never silence the
centuries of blood that's calling out to
us from the
ground do you hear it calling
we can learn a lot about a man by how he
reacts when his worst Deeds are exposed
does he acknowledge his sin and turn
away from it or does he justify it and
continue hurting others and even himself
Muhammad had an adopted son named zad
who was called zad bin Muhammad zad son
of Muhammad one day Muhammad went to
visit him and was greeted by zad's wife
zanab who was one of the most beautiful
women in Arabia and who was wearing very
little clothing at the time here's what
happened according to the Muslim
historian
tabi she jumped up in haste and excited
the admiration of the messenger of God
so that he turned away murmuring
something that could scarcely be
understood however he did say overtly
glory be to God the almighty glory be to
God who causes Hearts to
turn when zad found out that his wife
had excited the admiration of his
adopted father and prophet he decided to
divorce her so that Muhammad could have
her Muhammad however understood that
taking your adopted son's wife was
frowned upon by everyone in history so
he told zad no keep your wife
but by that time zanib had found out
that Muhammad was attracted to her and
seeing the opportunity to move up in the
world she began despising her husband
zad wanting to give his adopted father
and Prophet whatever he desired divorced
his wife and Muhammad married her not
surprisingly people started complaining
what sort of man marries a woman who
who's been having sex with his own
adopted
son how did Muhammad respond to the
criticism he started receiving
Revelations to justify the marriage
Allah revealed Surah 33: 4 to5
abolishing adoption in Islam from that
point on zad was no longer called
Muhammad's son Allah also revealed Surah
33: 37 where he explains why he wanted
Muhammad to marry zanab Allah says
and remember when you Muhammad said to
him to whom Allah had shown favor and to
whom you had shown favor keep your wife
to yourself and be careful of your duty
to Allah and you concealed in your soul
what Allah would bring to light and you
feared men and Allah had a greater right
that you should fear him but when zad
had accomplished his want of her I.E
divorced her we gave her to you as a
wife so that there should be no
difficulty for the Believers in respect
of the wives of their adopted Sons when
they have accomplished their want of
them and Allah's command shall be
performed Muslims defend Muhammad by
offering all kinds of explanations for
his marriage to zanab but in the Quran
we have Allah's explanation Allah says
to Muhammad we gave her to you as a wife
so that there should be no difficulty
for the Believers in respect of the
wives of their adopted Sons when they
have accomplished their want of them so
Allah gave zanib to Muhammad so that
other Muslim men would know that it's
okay to marry the divorced wives of
their adopted Sons three quick problems
with Allah's explanation one how many
men really struggle with whether or not
they should be marrying the divorced
wives of their own adopted Sons apart
from Muhammad I've never heard of anyone
who needed Divine guidance on this issue
and yet Allah is convinced that lots of
us are sitting around scratching our
heads thinking to ourselves wow my
adopted son's wife is so hot I wonder if
God wants me to have her second assuming
that Allah wants men to know that it's
okay to marry the divorced wives of
their own adopted sons does he really
need Muhammad to go out and do it
wouldn't it be enough for Allah to say
in the Quran hey guys in case you're
wondering yes it's perfectly acceptable
in Islam to start lusting after your
adopted Sons wives until your adopted
Sons divorce them and then you can marry
them is this such an incredibly
important issue that Allah not only had
to reveal a Quran verse about it but
also needed Muhammad to break up a
marriage and show us how it's done
third Allah abolished adoption in Surah
33: 4 to 5 Muslims are still free to
take care of Orphans but they don't
adopt them into their families so if
there's no more adoption in Islam why in
the name of Common Sense is Allah
telling Muhammad that he has to marry
zanib so that other Muslim men will know
that it's okay to marry the divorced
wives of their adopted Sons there aren't
going to be any more adopted Sons so the
situation isn't going to exist for
Muslims why would Allah tell Muhammad to
do something in order to set an example
for other Muslims facing the same
problem when there aren't going to be
any other Muslims facing the same
problem the only conclusion to draw is
that Muhammad was criticized for doing
something really really bad having
adulterous thoughts about his adopted
son's wife causing his adopted son to
divorce his wife and then marrying the
woman he was lusting after but instead
of admitting that he had done something
wrong he justified what he had done and
abolished one of Humanity's most Humane
practices in the
process worst adopted
father
ever how did Paul react when his sin was
exposed Paul was a violent persecutor of
the church when he realized that he was
wrong he confessed his sins turned away
from persecution and blasphemy
acknowledged that he could only be
forgiven through God's grace and spent
the rest of his life showing people how
to live for God once they've been
forgiven years later Paul said I thank
Christ Jesus our lord who has given me
strength that he considered me faithful
pointing me to his service even though I
was once a blasphemer and a persecutor
and the violent man I was shown Mercy
because I acted in ignorance and
unbelief the grace of our Lord was
poured out on me abundantly along with
the faith and love that are in Christ
Jesus here is a trustworthy saying that
deserves full acceptance Christ Jesus
came into the world to save Sinners of
whom I am the worst but for that very
reason I was shown mercy so that in me
the worst of sinners Christ Jesus might
display his UNL limited patience as an
example for those who would believe on
him and receive eternal life now to the
king Eternal Immortal invisible the only
God be honor and Glory forever and
ever
amen so with Paul we have a pattern for
people who have committed terrible acts
turn away from those acts seek
forgiveness don't make excuses with
Muhammad we have a very different
pattern justify your terrible acts and
continue doing them now here's a quick
question for our Muslim
friends I was once a violent man and I
did some of the worst things a human
being can do but I turned away from
violence and followed the pattern laid
down by Paul what sort of person do you
think I would be right now if I had
instead followed the pattern laid down
by
Muhammad would I be peacefully
discussing theological claims on YouTube
or would I be slaughtering people in the
name of
Allah you know the answer which means
that you understand the real world
impact your prophets teachings have on
people am I the only one who gets
suspicious when a guy who's supposedly
receiving Revelations ends up getting
all kinds of special moral privileges
from god let's consider three examples
that should raise some
eyebrows first the Quran says in Surah
4:3 that Muslim men can marry up to four
women but according to sah alkari and
numerous other Muslim sources Muhammad
had at least nine wives at one time if
Muslims are allowed to have no more than
four wives why did Muhammad get more
lucky him Allah decided in Surah 33: 50
that Muhammad and only Muhammad could
have as many wives as he wanted how
convenient second when Muhammad wanted
to marry Aisha who was 6 years old at
the time he said that Allah had given
him dreams about marrying her sah bukari
3895 narrated Aisha that the prophet
said to her you have been shown to me
twice in my dream I saw you pictured on
a piece of silk and someone said to me
this is your wife when I uncovered the
picture I saw that it was yours I said
if this is from Allah it will be
accomplished I think I speak for most
men when I say if you have a dream about
marrying your best friend's 6-year-old
daughter that dream didn't come from God
you're a pervert and you need to go see
a
psychiatrist third one day after
Muhammad got caught having sex with his
slave girl and his wife Hop's bed he
swore to his wives that he would stop
having sex with his slave girl but a
little later in Surah 66 veres 1 and 2
Allah rebuked Muhammad for making that
oath and he gave him permission to break
it and to start having sex with his
slave girl again since most people
aren't familiar with this story let's
read about the historical background of
Surah 66 verse1 of the Quran Sun anai
341 it was narrated from anus that the
messenger of Allah had a female slave
with whom he had intercourse but Aisha
and haa would not leave him alone until
he said that she was forbidden for him
then Allah the mighty and subblime
revealed oh Prophet why do you forbid
for yourself that which Allah has
allowed to you that's Surah 66:1 until
the end of the verse you can read more
of the juicy details in taper jalalain
Muhammad eventually got the slave girl
pregnant over the years Aisha picked up
on the fact that whenever Muhammad
wanted something he got a special
Revelation from Allah saying that he
could have it in sahkari 4788 Muhammad
receives one of his morally convenient
Revelations and Aisha says to him I feel
that your lord hastens in fulfilling
your wishes and
desires indeed there are times when
Allah seems like he has nothing better
to do than to encourage and justify
Muhammad's sexual
Adventures what about Paul well there's
not much to say about Paul's sex life
because he was apparently celibate from
his birth until his death Paul knew that
his life would be painful and difficult
and dangerous and that he would probably
be killed for his preaching and he just
didn't want to get married and put his
wife through all of that were there any
special moral privileges for Apostles no
God called Apostles to a higher moral
standard and a more difficult life not
to a lower moral standard and an easier
life Paul describes the life of an
apostle in 1 Corinthians four to this
very hour we go hungry and thirsty we
are in rags we are brutally treated we
are homeless we work hard with our own
hands when we are cursed we bless when
we are persecuted we endure it when we
are slandered we answer kindly we have
become the scum of the earth the garbage
of the world right up to this moment
become an apostle it's a great life and
Paul knew what he was getting into from
the beginning of his Christian Journey
when Jesus sent ananas to Paul shortly
after his encounter on the road to
Damascus Jesus said I will show him how
much he must suffer for my
name now suppose you meet two different
men both of whom claim to speak for God
one of them says God told me to preach
and that I would be horribly treated for
the rest of my life but that I must
remain faithful
anyway the other says God has spoken to
me and he says that he wants me to have
lots of women and girls and sex slaves
and that I get to rob people and
subjugate them and break my
Oaths obviously there are many other
factors to consider in evaluating their
reliability but if you had to choose
based solely on the lives their
Revelations called them
to which of these two men would would
you trust
more yeah me too I trust a revelation
from Muhammad about as much as I would
have trusted a revelation from Hugh
Hefner Paul and Muhammad went through
some profound changes during their
lifetimes but they eventually settled
into their final views on on various
topics we can get to the hearts of their
culminating ethical positions by asking
each of them a simple question as far as
ethics is concerned what's the greatest
thing in the world we have Paul's answer
in 1 Corinthians 13 where he writes if I
speak in the tongues of men and of
angels but have not love I am only a
resounding gong or a clanging symbol if
I have the gift of Prophecy and can
fathom all Mysteries and all knowledge
and if I have a faith that can move
mountains but have not love I am nothing
if I give all I possess to the poor and
surrender my body to the Flames but have
not love I gain nothing love is patient
love is kind it does not envy it does
not boast it is not proud it is not rude
it is not self-seeking it is not easily
angered it keeps no record of wrongs
love does not Delight in evil but
rejoices with the truth it always
protects always trusts always hopes
Always perseveres Love Never Fails but
where there are prophecies they will
cease where there are tongues they will
be stilled where there is knowledge it
will pass away for we know in part and
we prophesy in part but when Perfection
comes the imperfect disappears when I
was a child I talked like a child I
thought like a child I reasoned like a
child when I became a man I put childish
ways behind me now we see but a poor
reflection as in a mirror then we shall
see face to face now I know in part then
I shall know fully even as I am fully
known and now these three remain faith
hope and love but the greatest of these
is
love according to Paul what's the
greatest thing you can
do
love now for Muhammad's answer to the
question what's the greatest thing in
the world sahkari
2795 the prophet said nobody who dies
and finds good from Allah in Hereafter
would wish to come back to this world
even if he were given the whole world
and whatever is in it except the Martyr
who on seeing the superiority of
martyrdom would like to come back to the
world and get killed again in Allah's
cause the only thing that would be worth
coming back to this world for after
seeing Paradise is getting killed while
waging Jihad sah bukari
2796 the prophet said a single Endeavor
of fighting in Allah's cause in the
afternoon or in the for noon is better
than all the world and whatever is in it
a single attack by a Jihadi is better
than the entire world and everything in
it and we wonder why Muslim mothers send
their kids off to join terrorist groups
they're just doing what's best for their
children according to Muhammad sahkari
2797 Muhammad said by him in whose hands
my soul is I would love to be martyred
in Allah's cause and then come back to
life and then get Marty and then come
back to life again and then get martyred
and then come back to life again and
then get
martyred according to Muhammad what's
the greatest thing you can do die while
slaughtering unbelievers in the name of
Allah in John 10 verse 10 Jesus says the
thief comes only to steal and kill and
destroy I have come that they may have
life and have it to the
full if the forces of evil come to steal
and kill and destroy and the Pinnacle of
Muhammad's hierarchy of Good Deeds is
getting killed while slaughtering people
but Jesus came so that people would have
life to the full and the Pinnacle of
Paul's hierarchy of Good Deeds is loving
people who ethical system would Jesus
affirm Paul's or
Muhammad's whose ethical system would
Jesus
condemn if you Muslims know that Jesus
would condemn Muhammad why do you keep
telling us that you respect Jesus
Muhammad preached in Mecca for more than
a decade at first in private and then
publicly but he didn't win very many
converts through preaching submission to
Allah we don't see large numbers of
converts to Islam until Muhammad
modified his message and his tactics
after years of unconvincing messages
about Islam Muhammad made an enticing
guarantee to those who waged Jihad for
him a message that resonated with many
7th Century Arabs in sah alari 2787
Muhammad says the example of a mujahid a
Jihadi in Allah's cause and Allah knows
better who really strives in his cause
is like a person who observes s fasting
and offers Salat prayer continuously
Allah guarantees that he will admit the
mujahid in his cause into Paradise if he
is killed otherwise he will return him
to his home safely with rewards and War
booty Muhammad guaranteed that if you
wage Jihad for him you'll either die in
which case you'll enter paradise and get
your virgins or you'll survive in which
case you'll return home safely with
rewards and War booty which includes sex
slaves so either way whether you live or
die it's to your financial and sexual
advantage to fight for Muhammad Muhammad
clearly understood that the quickest way
to the hearts of his listeners was
through their wallets or their pants for
example when Muhammad was accused of
Distributing The Spoils of War unevenly
favoring potential converts he replied
are you disturbed in mind because of the
good things of this life by which I win
over a people that they may become
Muslims while I entrust you to your
Islam in sahkari 3344 Muhammad divides a
piece of gold among four Chiefs of a
different tribe Watch What
Happens so the K and the ansar became
angry and said he I.E the prophet gives
to the chiefs of najed and does not give
to us the prophet said I give to them so
as to attract their hearts to
Islam so for the early Muslims the
importance of money and captives as a
motive for conversion can hardly be
overstated but Muhammad also knew how to
convert people who didn't want to accept
Islam just to get gold or sex slaves he
would fight them until they converted in
sah Muslim 129 Muhammad declares I have
been commanded to fight the people until
they bear witness that none has the
right to be worshiped but Allah and that
Muhammad is the messenger of Allah and
they establish the Salat and pay the
zakat if they do that then their blood
and wealth are protected from me except
for a right that is you and their
Reckoning will be with
Allah Muhammad made it very clear that
if you didn't convert to Islam you were
a target for Jihad now think about the
alternatives for a 7th Century Pagan
Arab if you converted and fought for
Muhammad you'd get rewards and War booty
if you didn't convert he was coming to
kill
you was this method successful let's
read Abu bak's summary of muham
Muhammad's life and work in the history
of atab volume 10 page 55 Abu Bakr
declares verily God may he be exalted
sent Muhammad with his truth to his
creation as a bearer of good tidings and
as a Warner and as one calling others to
God with his permission and as a light
bringing lamp so that he might warn all
who live and so that the saying against
the unbelievers might be fulfilled so
God got Ed with the truth whoever
responded to him and the Apostle of God
with his permission struck whoever
turned his back to him until he came to
Islam willingly or
grudgingly so Muhammad preached but the
secret to his success was intimidation
and bribery the Apostle Paul after his
conversion relied strictly on Peaceful
preaching rather than on bribes or
threats of physical violence Paul
presented his listeners with a simple
message Jesus died on the cross for sins
his crucifixion was a public event but
he didn't stay dead he rose and appeared
to numerous Witnesses both friends and
foes Jesus resurrection confirms his
message so you need to submit to him as
Lord this was the same message preached
by Jesus original Apostles indeed when
Paul preached in various cities he would
share the early EST Christian Creed
which he had received from the apostles
themselves Paul writes to the Christians
of Corinth in 1 Corinthians 15 for I
delivered to you as of first importance
what I also received this is where the
Creed starts that Christ died for our
sins according to the scriptures and
that he was buried and that he was
raised on the third day according to the
scriptures and that he appeared to
sephus I.E Peter then to the 12 after
that he appeared to more than 500
Brethren at one time most of whom remain
until now but some have fallen asleep
then he appeared to James then to all
the apostles and last of all as to one
untimely born he appeared to me
also Scholars even critical Scholars
date this Creed to within just a few
years of jesus' death which makes it
extremely early
material and what does it say that Jesus
died on the cross for sins that he rose
from the dead that there are lots of
witnesses and that this was all
prophesied centuries
beforehand Paul's listeners understood
that this message was different from
other religious messages Paul's
preaching was grounded in evidence and
observation and people converted to
Christianity wherever he went the
evidence for Christianity was so
persuasive that within just a few
centuries Christianity conquered the
most powerful Empire the world had ever
seen without Christians ever needing to
turn to violence or
bribery it seems that when you have a
good argument you don't need to kill and
rape until people are forced to agree
with
you Paul and Muhammad were both
persecuted Paul was persecuted for
preaching the gospel
Muslims think that Muhammad was
persecuted for preaching Islam but
that's not what their sources say
Muhammad was persecuted for mocking the
gods and goddesses of the pagans of
Mecca we read in the history ofab volume
6 page 93 the messenger of God
proclaimed God's message openly and
declared Islam publicly to his fellow
tribesmen when he did so they did not
withdraw from him or reject him in any
way as far as I have heard until he
spoke of their gods and denounced them
when he did this they took exception to
it and United in opposition and
hostility to him except for those of
them whom God had protected from error
by means of Islam a few pages later
Muhammad's tribesmen describe Muhammad's
General approach towards reaching
polytheists with The Message of Islam we
have never seen the like of what we have
endured from this man he has derided our
Traditional Values abused our
forefathers reviled our religion caused
division Among Us and insulted our Gods
we have endured a great deal from
him now that's strange Muslims in the
west tell me that it's wrong and immoral
to criticize another person's religious
beliefs and yet their favorite Prophet
viciously mocked other people's
religious
beliefs so the polytheists of Mecca
responded by persecuting Muhammad
Muslims tend to exaggerate the level of
persecution Muhammad faced however the
pagans threw pebbles at him they spit on
him they eventually decided to kill him
but this persecution only lasted a few
years until Muhammad moved to Medina
that's when the persecuted Muhammad
became Muhammad the
persecutor in comparing the lives of
Muhammad and Paul we quickly realize
that the persecution Muhammad suffered
was a joke compared to the persecution
Paul suffered Paul gives us a partial
overview of his trials in 2 Corinthians
11 I have worked much harder been in
prison more frequently been flogged more
severely and been exposed to death again
and again five times I received from the
Jews the 40 Lashes minus one three times
I was beaten with rods once I was pelted
with stones three times I was
Shipwrecked I spent a night and a day in
the open sea I have been constantly on
the move I have been in danger from
rivers in danger from bandits in danger
from my fellow Jews in danger from
Gentiles in danger in the city in danger
in the country in danger at Sea and in
danger from false Believers I have
labored and toiled and have often Gone
without sleep I have known hunger and
thirst and have often Gone without food
I have been cold and naked
Paul wrote these words in the mid-50s ad
he still had years of beatings and
imprisonments ahead of him so by the end
of his life most of his body would have
been covered in Scar
Tissue the reason this is important is
that the more you're persecuted the more
you'll be inclined to stop and think is
that really a revelation from God that I
received I need to be sure because it's
costing me a lot we know know that Paul
had complete confidence in his
Revelations because he endured outright
torture over and over and over again
Muhammad was persecuted but given the
endless supply of wives and sex slaves
and money and special moral privileges
that only applied to him we'll just
never know how long he would have
endured if he had faced anything
remotely resembling what Paul
faced on a side note I'm always amazed
at the Muslim reaction to the
persecution of Muhammad in Mecca Muslims
look to this period and complain about
the intolerant pagans how could they
persecute our beloved Prophet why were
they so bigoted and
islamophobic but let's be consistent for
just a moment Muhammad preached openly
against the religious beliefs of the
people of Mecca for about 10 years and
he
survived if I went to Mecca today and
preached openly against the religious
beliefs of the people who live there now
would I last 10
years would I last 10
months 10
days 10
hours if I stood outside the cabba and
began openly preaching against the
religious beliefs of the people of Mecca
today would I last 10
minutes Muslims complain about the
intolerance of the pagans who opposed
Muhammad and yet the pagans were far far
more tolerant than the man who
subjugated
them welcome to Islam where tolerance
much like Muhammad's sexual attraction
to his child bride Aisha is a one-way
street according to Muslim sources when
Muhammad received his first revelation
in the cave on Mount H he believed that
he was possessed by a demon and if you
read what the Muslim sources say about
how Muhammad received his Revelations
you'll understand why he thought he was
possessed his encounters with Gabriel
sound like something out of an exorcist
film Muhammad's face would turn red his
heart would race the veins and his neck
would swell up his shoulders would
tremble he would come down with a fever
his lips would move rapidly he would
hear ringing of voices he would sweat
profusely even in the cold according to
Muslim sources once Muhammad became
convinced that he was demon-possessed he
tried to commit suicide by hurling
himself off a cliff according to Muslim
sources Muhammad delivered Revelations
to his followers promoting polytheism
the infamous Satanic Verses after while
he came back and said that Satan had
tricked him into delivering these verses
apparently Muhammad just couldn't tell
the difference between inspiration from
God and inspiration from the devil
according to Muslim sources Muhammad was
the victim of black magic that gave him
delusional thoughts and false beliefs
this is crucial because the Quran tells
us that magic is taught by demons since
magic was successful over Muhammad
demons had power over
Muhammad I can't imagine someone less
reliable on a spiritual level than the
prophet of
Islam Paul by contrast was not a
helpless victim of demonic attacks
demons were victims of Paul attacks Paul
would cast them out Paul became so
famous for his ability to cast out
demons that other people tried to cast
out demons by saying I cast you out in
the name of Jesus whom Paul
preaches this didn't work because you
have to actually know Jesus in order to
have that kind of Spiritual Authority
but it shows that Paul's power over
demons was known even among
non-christians so Paul had power over
demons demons had power over
Muhammad transitive
property whom should we be listening to
the Apostle Paul performed numerous
Miracles during his missionary Journeys
including healing a man who was disabled
since birth and even raising a young man
named udcus from the dead Paul lived
such a miraculous life that people would
touch him with a cloth take the cloth to
a sick person and the sick person would
be healed healed many Muslims are
convinced that Muhammad performed
Miracles but it's important to note one
that stories about Muhammad's Miracles
were written more than a century after
his death two that they were written
during a time when Muslims were forging
stories about their Prophet like it was
an Olympic sport and three that they
were written in response to repeated
challenges from Jews and Christians who
wanted to know why Muhammad couldn't
perform
Miracles our earliest Islamic source is
the Quran and the Quran repeatedly
admits that Muhammad couldn't perform
any Miracles other than delivering the
Quran Surah 6:
37 and they say why has not a sign been
sent down to him from his Lord say
surely Allah is able to send down a sign
but most of them do not know sah 10
verse 20 and they say why is not a sign
sent to him from his Lord say the Unseen
is only for Allah therefore wait surely
I too with you am of those who wait sah
13:7 and those who disbelieve say why
has not a sign been sent down upon him
from his Lord you are only a Warner and
there is a guide for every people sorah
13 ver 27 and those who disbelieve say
why is not a sign sent down upon him by
his is Lord say surely Allah makes him
who will go astray and guides to himself
those who turn to him Surah
17:59 and nothing could have hindered us
that we should send signs except that
the Ancients rejected them and we gave
to samud a she camel a manifest sign but
on her account they did Injustice and we
do not send signs but to make men fear
sah 29:
50-51 and they say why are not signs
sent down upon him from his Lord say the
signs are only with Allah and I am only
a plain Warner is it not enough for them
that we have revealed to you the book
which is recited to them so Allah makes
a variety of excuses for not giving
mammad any Miracles but embedded in
these excuses is an admission that
muhammmad couldn't perform Miracles
hence unless Muslims want us to reject
the Quran we're forced to conclude that
the prophet of Islam was a about as
miraculous as a can of cheese whiz as
for Muhammad's claim that the Quran
itself is a miracle I give him an award
for worst argument ever but I'm fresh
out of blue
ribbons following his conversion the
Apostle Paul spent about three decades
preaching the gospel during that that
time there were numerous plots to kill
him the Romans eventually succeeded in
the mid 60s ad because Paul was a Roman
citizen he was executed by beheading
rather than by crucifixion since Paul
had been preaching to the Roman soldiers
and leaders his martyrdom served as a
witness to the very people who executed
him our word martyr comes from a Greek
word meaning witness so Paul died an
honorable death as a
martyr how did Muhammad die well after
Muhammad and his followers had attacked
the Jewish settlement at kabar a Jewish
woman whose father uncle and husband had
all been slaughtered by Muhammad's
followers offered to cook a meal for
Muhammad and his
companions and as we all know if a woman
whose family you've just butchered
offers to cook you a delicious meal you
say yes so Muhammad gladly accepted the
invitation the woman poisoned the
roasted lamb she was serving one of
Muhammad's companions died from the
poison Muhammad spit the food out and
survived but the poison did some sort of
internal damage that led to ongoing
medical problems a few years later
Muhammad complained to the mother of the
man who had died from the poison that he
could feel the poison killing him too
the history of at tabari volume 8 page
124 the messenger of God said during the
illness from which he died the mother of
bisher Bin albar had come in to visit
him um bisher at this very moment I feel
my aorta being severed because of the
food I ate with your son at
Kar mamad felt his aorta being severed
because of the food he ate at kabar he
said the same thing to Aisha as he was
dying sah bukari
44:28 the prophet in his ailment in
which he died used to say oh Aisha I
still feel the pain caused by the food I
ate at kabar and at this time I feel as
if my aorta is being cut from that
poison I should point out that the words
as if are not in the Arabic Muhammad
doesn't say he feels as if his aorta is
being severed he says that he feels his
aorta being severed from the
poison why are these references to
Muhammad feeling his aorta being severed
significant if we are examining the
manner of his death well in the Quran
Allah tells us how he would kill
Muhammad if Muhammad ever forged a
revelation let's read three translations
of Surah 69: 44- 46 to see how Allah
would kill Muhammad for inventing
Revelations hell Khan and if he Muhammad
had forged a false saying concerning us
we surely should have seized him by his
right hand or with power and might and
then certainly should have cut off his
life artery and in parenthesis the
translators add
aorta pickthal and if he had invented
false sayings concerning us we assuredly
had taken him by the right hand and then
severed his life AR
MH Shakir and if he had fabricated
against us some of the sayings we would
certainly have seized him by the right
hand then we would certainly have cut
off his
aorta what did Allah say that the
penalty would be for fabricating
Revelations he said that the penalty
would be cutting off Muhammad's
aort and what did Muhammad himself say
that the poison had done to
him he said that it had cut off his
aorta so while Paul died an honorable
death as a martyr Muhammad died a
disgraceful death as a false prophet
given Muhammad's treatment of women Jews
and followers of Jesus it's almost
poetic that he was killed by a lamb
given to him by a Jewish woman
ultimately severing his aorta confirming
his status as a false prophet
humiliations
Galore Allah confirms the reliability of
the Apostle Paul in chapter 61:4 of the
Quran Allah says that he aided the true
followers of Jesus until they became
uppermost over those who rejected Jesus
Allah says oh who believe be helpers in
the cause of Allah as Jesus Son of Mary
said to his disciples who are my helpers
in the cause of Allah the disciples said
we are helpers in the cause of Allah so
a party of the children of Israel
believed and another party disbelieved
then we aided those who believed against
their enemy and they became
uppermost in his commentary on this
verse YF Ali says that it refers to
Allah aing the Christians until they
permeated the Roman Empire but the
Christians who permeated the Roman
Empire were what Muslims would call
Pauline Christians they believed in the
message and authority of the Apostle
Paul so if Allah helped the true
Christians rise to power and the
Christians who Rose to power believed in
the message and authority of the Apostle
Paul we have a Law's stamp of approval
on the Apostle
Paul one of the most respected Muslim
commentators of all time Cort comments
on Surah
61:4 as
follows it was said that this verse was
revealed about the Apostles of Jesus may
peace and blessings be upon Him Ian asak
stated that of the Apostles and
disciples that Jesus sent to preach
there were Peter and Paul who went to
Rome this is a Muslim scholar telling us
that Paul was sent by Jesus the Muslim
musl historian tabri agrees that Paul
was a follower of Jesus he writes among
the apostles and the followers who came
after them were the Apostle Peter and
Paul who was a follower and not an
apostle they went to
Rome why would respected Muslim
commentators list Paul among the true
Witnesses of Jesus who preached in Rome
the reason they describe Paul this way
is that many classical Muslim
commentators unlike Muslims today based
their views on the Quran Allah said that
he sent the gospel as a guidance for
mankind and that he would protect Jesus
followers so these commentators realized
that to say that the Apostle Paul
corrupted the gospel is to insult Allah
if Allah sent the gospel as a guidance
and promised to protect jesus' followers
but was overpowered by the Apostle Paul
this would make Paul more powerful than
Allah so when modern mus Muslims tell us
that Allah's plans were foiled by the
Apostle Paul they're not making Paul
look bad they're making Paul greater
than their God these Muslims need to
change the takir from Allah Akbar to
bulu
Akbar so the Quran affirms the
reliability of Paul we can trust what
Paul says according to a law and what
does Paul say Galatians 1: 8-9 but even
if we or an angel from heaven should
preach to you a gospel contrary to what
we have preached to you he is to be a
cursed as we have said before so I say
again now if any man is preaching to you
a gospel contrary to what you received
he is to be a
cursed Paul says that anyone who
preaches a gospel different from the one
he preached to the Galatians is under
God's curse but Muhammad preached a
gospel different from the one Paul
preached to the
Galatians hence Muhammad is under God's
curse the only way for Muslims to avoid
this conclusion is to say that Paul was
a deceiver who corrupted Jesus message
but as we've seen the Quran affirms the
reliability of Paul and since Allah
promised to protect Jesus true followers
and claimed that no one can change his
words the only way Paul could have
corrupted Jesus message and led his
followers astray was to overpower Allah
which brings Muslims back to their new
T bullas
Akbar Paul's message about Jesus and the
gospel is the same message we find
prophesied in the Old Testament the same
message preached by Jesus and his
original followers
you are not good enough to enter the
presence of God all our righteousness is
as filthy rags before God if you think
you're good enough to meet God you have
a pretty low view of God and that's part
of the problem what this means is that
if we want to be accepted by God we need
a righteousness that comes from God not
from ourselves the gospel is a message
about how God gives us this
righteousness through Jesus Christ
you might not like the message but
there's nothing incoherent or illogical
about it Muhammad's message by contrast
self-destructs because the Quran affirms
the inspiration preservation and
authority of scriptures that completely
contradict
Islam in Surah 3: 3 to 4 Allah says that
he revealed the Torah and the gospel in
Surah 7: 157 Allah says that Christians
were still reading the gospel during the
time of Muhammad we have copies of the
Gospel before the time of Muhammad
during the time of Muhammad and after
the time of Muhammad so we know what the
gospel during Muhammad's time said we've
still got it in Surah 6 verse 115 and
Surah 18: 27 Allah says that no one can
change his words no one is powerful
enough to change Allah's words recall
that Allah already said that the Torah
and the gospel are his words which means
that the Torah and the gospel cannot be
corrupted not surprisingly according to
the Quran the gospel is still
authoritative scripture Allah even
commands Christians to judge by what we
read in the gospel he says in sah
5:47 let the people of the Gospel judge
by what Allah hath revealed therein if
any do fail to judge by the light of
what Allah hath revealed they are no
better than those who
Rebel so Allah says that he revealed the
gospel inspiration he says that no one
can change his words preservation and He
commands Christians to judge by the
gospel
Authority the problem for Islam is that
if we judge by the gospel as Allah
commands we have to reject Islam because
the gospel plainly declares that Jesus
is the Divine Son of God who who died on
the cross for sins and rose from the
dead and that anyone who comes against
this message is not from
God there are only two possibilities
here my friends either Christians have
the inspired preserved authoritative
word of God or we don't if we have the
word of God Islam is false because Islam
contradicts our
scriptures if we don't have the word of
God it's Islam is false because Islam
affirms our scriptures if we have the
word of God Islam is false and if we
don't have the word of God Islam is
false either way Islam is false unlike
Paul's message Muhammad's message
self-destructs in case you're wondering
yes this would be an excellent time for
our Muslim friends to start looking for
a new prophet
Muslims maintain that Jesus was one of
Allah's mightiest prophets but if we
take a closer look at their claims we
can see that if Islam is true Jesus was
the most stupendous failure in the
history of the prophets since he started
preaching Islam at Birth according to
the Quran he had more than 30 years to
convince people to submit to Allah law
but after his death the children of
Israel were divided into two broad camps
those who believed his message became
Christians all of whom were guilty of
the worst sin imaginable Sher or
associating a partner with Allah while
those who rejected his message were
guilty of rejecting one of Allah's
mightiest Messengers so whether people
believed in Jesus or rejected him they
would all ultimately be condemned and
cast into the
fire Jesus didn't manage to win a single
lasting convert to Islam his devout
Muslim followers were all LED
astray who led them
astray this is where Muslims like to
claim that the Apostle Paul deceived the
early Christian Community notice that
this would be an admission that
according to Islam all the work that
Jesus did Came Crashing Down due to
corruption but it gets worse because
Islam doesn't actually teach that Paul
corrupted Jesus message Islam teaches
that Allah corrupted Jesus message when
he tricked people into believing that
Jesus died on the cross according to the
Quran Jesus didn't die by
crucifixion but all four gospels say
that Jesus died by crucifixion where did
people get the idea that Jesus died by
crucifixion they got it from Allah who
miraculously disguised someone to make
him look like Jesus so who's responsible
for corrupting Jesus
message
Allah the poor Islamic Jesus spent his
entire life preaching only to have his
life's work sabotaged by The God Who
promised to protect his
followers so according to Islam Jesus
accomplished absolutely nothing of any
lasting
significance we have no record of his
Muslim disciples or of Jesus preaching
anything similar to Islam the Islamic
Jesus was a total failure and Muslims
claim to respect
Jesus what about Paul does Paul also
insult and degrade Jesus with his
message not at all we have a good
summary of Paul's view in Philippians 2
where Paul quotes an early Christian
hymn Paul tells the
Philippians in your relationships with
one another have the same mindset as
Christ Jesus who being in very nature
God did not consider equality with God
something to be used to his own
Advantage rather he made himself Nothing
by taking the very nature of a servant
being made in human likeness and being
found in appearance as a man he humbled
himself by becoming obedient to death
even death on a cross therefore God
exalted him to the highest place and
gave him the the name that is above
every name that at the name of Jesus
every knee should bow in heaven and on
Earth and under the Earth and every
tongue acknowledge that Jesus Christ is
Lord to the glory of God the
Father Paul certainly isn't insulting
Jesus here Paul says that Jesus being in
very nature God didn't consider that
equality with the father something he
had to hold on to he took on human
nature and died on the cross he then
returned to his glorified State and now
every knee will bow before him and every
tongue will confess that Jesus is Lord
this means that Adam and Noah and
Abraham and Moses and King David and yes
especially Muhammad will all bow before
their Risen
Lord On a related note since Paul was
quoting a first century Christian hymn
we know that the earliest Christians
were already singing songs about the
deity of Christ and the
Incarnation but the hymn also draws a
distinction between Jesus who is God and
the father who is God which means that
we can't understand the earliest
Christian worship without the doctrine
of the
Trinity so for you Muslims who've been
told by your Scholars that belief in the
deity of Christ arose centuries after
the time of
Jesus you need some new Scholars
preferably some who don't constantly lie
to
you Muslims claim to have an impeccable
theology but they believe in a God who
deceives people for no reason as when he
tricked people into believing that Jesus
died on the cross starts false religions
as when he accidentally helped start
Christ Christianity by convincing a
bunch of first century Jews that Jesus
had died on the cross and overthrows the
work of His prophets as when he
corrupted Jesus message by turning it
into a message about Jesus work on the
cross Allah deceives People starts false
religions and overthrows the work of His
prophets even though he calls himself
the truth promises to protect those who
follow His prophets and boasts that no
one can change his words although in his
defense does repeatedly call himself the
best of
deceivers Allah sent Jesus with the
gospel forgetting that he was just going
to corrupt the gospel and allow it to be
further corrupted by others and that he
would deceive Jesus followers and allow
them to be further deceived by
others if Islam is true God is ignorant
and deceptive Jesus was irrelevant and
incompetent and Jesus followers were
weak willed and and
unreliable Islam is one massive insult
to God as with so many of Islam's claims
we find superficial reverence but deep
blasphemy on the surface Islam sounds
like it promotes reverence for God but
as soon as we dig a Little Deeper we
find Blasphemous incoherent
nonsense this is exactly what we should
expect from a false religion reverence
on the surface BL blasphemy below the
surface superficial reverence deep
blasphemy Paul by contrast honors God
the god of the Bible is perfect in his
attributes according to Christianity
God's justice is perfect so all sin must
be punished if God let some sin slide he
wouldn't be perfect in his justice but
God's love and mercy are also perfect
which means that he's vastly more loving
than we are so much so that he's willing
to take the punishment that we deserve
upon
himself God loves Sinners so much that
he entered into Creation in order to pay
the price for our sins as Jesus of
Nazareth he fulfilled his mission
perfectly and suffered for our sake so
that we could stand before God with the
righteousness of Christ Jesus taught the
good news the gospel to his followers he
appeared to them as their Risen Lord and
he sent the Holy Spirit to fill them and
Empower them those followers endured
torture and death to preach the gospel
to people who were lost and to make sure
that the gospel would reach
us so according to Paul God was
completely Victorious Jesus was
completely Victorious and Jesus
followers by God's grace were completely
Victorious Paul doesn't promote
superficial reverence he promotes deep
re
reverence Jesus warned his followers
that false prophets would come he also
commanded us not to believe them one of
the ways we can spot false prophets is
by carefully Discerning when their
teachings insult and demean God and
diminish God's perfect
attributes God is truth and God is
love Islam when carefully examined would
have us believe otherwise
so we have much earlier records for
Paul's life than for Muhammad's life
Paul was a brilliant scholar Muhammad
was an illiterate 7th Century Caravan
traitor Paul knew the Old Testament
backwards and forwards Muhammad wouldn't
know the Old Testament from a phone book
Paul was a contemporary of Jesus
Muhammad was born more than 5 centuries
later in a different country Paul spoke
all PA of the relevant languages
Muhammad spoke none of the relevant
languages Jesus sent Paul as an apostle
but condemned Muhammad as a false
prophet Paul tested his Revelations
Muhammad didn't test his Revelations
even when Allah told him too Paul's
message and Authority were confirmed by
Jesus original Apostles Jesus original
Apostles condemned Muhammad's teachings
as the teachings of an antichrist
Muhammad's other Revelations about
historical figures destroy his
credibility Paul's don't the Historical
Method supports Paul's view of Jesus and
refutes Muhammad's view of Jesus
Muhammad's teachings were heavily
influenced by paganism Paul's weren't
Muhammad's message flowed directly from
his surroundings and his psychological
State Paul's message required a radical
transformation Muhammad lived a morally
reprehensible life Paul didn't Paul
confessed his sins and repented Ed
Muhammad Justified his sins and
continued in them Muhammad's Revelations
were self-serving Paul's weren't Paul's
Revelations made him a better person
Muhammad's Revelations made him a worse
person Paul won converts through
peaceful preaching Muhammad won converts
primarily through bribes and threats
Paul endured greater persecution than
Muhammad Muhammad was spiritually
Disturbed Paul wasn't Paul performed
form Med Miracles Muhammad didn't Paul
died an honorable death as a martyr
Muhammad died a disgraceful death as a
false prophet the Quran affirms the
reliability of Paul but Paul condemns
Muhammad Muhammad's message
self-destructs Paul's doesn't Muhammad's
message insults Jesus Paul's message
honors Jesus Muhammad's message insults
God Paul's message honors
God every Poss possible way we can
compare these two men in terms of their
reliability Paul wins so we're looking
for someone to tell us the truth about
Jesus and on the one hand we have Paul
who may be the most trustworthy human
witness of Jesus ever other people might
be more reliable in particular ways but
when we look at the entire collection of
features that make Paul a reliable
witness scholarly training knowledge of
the Old Testament and of various Lang
languages a desire to test his
Revelations confirmation by Jesus and
his original followers impenetrable
moral fiber Miracles power over demons
patient endurance in the face of
persecution even to the point of
martyrdom who's more reliable than the
Apostle
Paul are you starting to understand why
Jesus chose Paul as an
apostle on the other hand we have an
illiterate Caravan traiter from the
wrong place at the wrong time who stands
condemned by Jesus and by his original
Apostles and by Paul who didn't test his
Revelations who delivered all sorts of
nonsensical Revelations about other
historical figures who was influenced by
his Pagan surroundings and his abnormal
psychology who lived a morally
reprehensible life and Justified his
sins and received self-serving
Revelations who won converts primarily
through bribes and intimidation who was
spiritually Disturbed ADM Ed L
delivering a revelation from Satan and
claiming to be a victim of black magic
whose entire message self-destructs
because he affirmed books that
contradict his own book whose message
insults God Jesus and Jesus Apostles and
whose death exposes him as a false
prophet according to the standard
supplied by his own Revelations show me
anyone less reliable than Muhammad if
we're having a discussion about
Jesus and yet our Muslim friends in
that when the least reliable person in
history tells us about Jesus and the
claims of the least reliable person in
history contradict known facts about
Jesus we should put the blame on the
most reliable person in history and call
him a deceiver so that we can go on
believing the claims of the least
reliable person in
history this is how Islam forces its
adherence to think to call this a
ridiculous methodology would be an
insult to all other ridiculous
methodologies Paul completely outclasses
Muhammad and guess what Muslims of the
world Paul's not even our main
guy Jesus is our main guy Paul a guy
who's not even our main guy thoroughly
embarrasses your only guy you've only
got one guy Muhammad you think you've
got God and angels and Prophets and so
on but it's really just one guy telling
you what to believe about everyone
else one guy telling you what to believe
about 50 other guys doesn't mean you've
got 51
Witnesses it's still just one guy in
Christianity we don't have to base our
beliefs on a single witness the prophets
who came before Jesus confirmed his
message Jesus disciples confirmed his
message the father confirmed his mage
message the Holy Spirit confirmed his
message Angels confirmed his message we
have a cloud of witnesses affirming our
beliefs even without
Paul Paul is simply another witness
confirming the gospel and all of our
Witnesses father son Holy Spirit Angels
prophets Apostles men women Jews
Gentiles everyone is united in affirming
the core of the gospel and in condemning
Muhammad as the most obvious false
prophet in
history but when Christians follow the
example of the Apostle Paul and we show
you how many lies you've believed
because it never occurred to you to
question what your leaders and your
parents told
you you get angry at
us you don't get angry at them for
filling your heads with nonsense you get
angry at us
and to that I reply in the words of the
Apostle
Paul have I now become your
enemy by telling you the truth
[Music]